ratchet and clank rift apart has finally
arrived and much like its predecessors
there's a little bit more going on under
the hood than you might think
to help you in the adventure ahead we've
put together 12
essential tips to get you started for
more on ratchet and clank make sure to
like this video and subscribe
to our channel while you're here if
you're familiar with the ratchet and
clank series it shouldn't surprise you
that rift apart has quite the arsenal of
weapons
each one has its own unique
functionality that helps quell the
hordes of enemies you'll encounter in a
firefight
some weapons are better for short range
like the shatter bomb and the enforcer
while others like negatron collider and
mr fungi
are better for long range or supporting
fire the more you play the more you'll
notice that multiple weapons fill out
near identical roles in battle which can
make it easy to pigeonhole yourself into
only using the same two or three weapons
instead of investing in others
while we understand the impulse to stick
to what you're comfortable with
try diversifying your weapon use instead
something you'll learn
early on is that your weapons level up
the more you use them
each maxes out at level 5 which
essentially upgrades it to its best
version
adding a powerful new perk that further
enhances its power
effectiveness but you might ask why
should i care about this if i don't want
to use the weapon to start with
well you never know how a weapon might
turn out by level 5.
something like the negetron collider may
not seem all that great at first
but once it achieves its max level it
gains the ability to trigger an
explosion at the end of every use
that is a great perk to have when
there's a ton of enemies coming at you
diversifying your weapon use is also
important because you might find that
some weapons fit combat situations
better than
others or that you might prefer one over
another for example a rapid fire type
weapon like the lightning rod is
actually a nice alternative to the blast
pistol because
it can leave behind shock trails that
damage nearby enemies which is arguably
more effective at bringing the hurt onto
groups
every weapon ultimately has its own
distinct strengths
even if some are similar to others but
there's a nuance to each that's worth
discovering
if only to help you perform that much
better or to simply increase your
enjoyment in a chaotic gunfight
when enemies start to surround you at
the start of a fight your first impulse
is to likely go
all-out guns blazing but if you're an
old-timer ratchet and clank player you
know that that's not always the best way
to start
usually when bullets start flying in
your general direction it's best to set
up a solid defense with your support
weapons first in rift apart these are mr
fungi
glove of doom bombardier cold snap and
the toppery sprinkler
all weapons that are designed to either
provide supporting fire
divert attention or immobilize enemies
at the start of a fight you'll generally
want to throw out your assist weapons
like mr fungi or the glove of doom's
robots to even the odds a bit
it's worth noting that you can throw
multiple of each onto the field so if
you desperately need the help against a
ruthless wave of enemies you can never
go wrong
throwing out two or even three of each
but unfortunately
this does not apply to the bombardier if
you need some breathing room it's a good
idea to use either the toepry sprinkler
or cold snap
to stop incoming enemies in their tracks
we prefer the former as
its set it and forget it functionality
makes for fewer headaches
however the cold snap can be fired on
mass and quickly incapacitate enemies
more intentionally
support weapons are some of the most
useful in the game as they help take the
heat off of you
especially against bosses giving ample
opportunity to unleash heavy damage onto
foes
while they're distracted never forget to
utilize those handy weapons at the start
of every fight
and frequently thereafter try not to
spend your raritanium recklessly as it's
the game's
only limited commodity at least on a per
play through basis
if you have weapons you particularly
like and want to invest in
focus on levelling them up first to open
up their gold cell pathways in the
upgrade tree
as you'll note from the game's tutorial
on the subject these special perk
bonuses enhance weapons in
incredibly useful ways so it's better to
save your raritanium for unlocking these
slots first and foremost instead of
upgrading
every available node since raritanium is
limited during a single playthrough you
might want to consider upgrading a
single weapon as early as possible
especially if you're looking to unlock
the there's even a cup holder trophy
your weapon wheel is a quick way to
access all your weapons obviously but
you can actually use the d-pad to switch
weapons too
granted it can only map a total of four
so you'll generally want to ensure your
favorite weapons are mapped to each
direction
to change your d-pad quick swap settings
simply bring up the weapon wheel
highlight a weapon and press the
corresponding d-pad direction to map it
while we understand the desire to hoard
your bolts you should never hesitate to
fork them over to buy any
and all weapons that are available at
mizorcon's shop definitely prioritize
buying the ones you think are most
beneficial to you first but even then
clearing a new level or two will
frequently supply you with
more than enough bolts to buy any
weapons you didn't get it's worth
pointing out that ms zircon will
frequently list
new weapons she has coming in stock
ahead of time these usually become
available upon starting up a new planet
so if you've got a lot of bolts on you
and are about to finish up a level
it's sometimes best to wait until the
next planet to give yourself
a more optimal selection ultimately
there's no reason to hold on to your
riches so
spend spend spend it can be pretty easy
to stick to one
area of a battle arena strafing left and
right as you pick off enemies coming at
you but that's an easy way to get
yourself
surrounded whenever you enter a new area
always take note of the rifts
since they can be incredibly useful for
avoiding enemy fire or running away if a
fight gets out of hand
if you're ever in danger pull into a
rift to keep yourself moving because you
know what they say
a moving target is harder to hit than a
stationary one
well in this case it's more like a
target that jumps through an
interdimensional portal
is harder to hit than a stationary one
much like a crack in time clank's rift
sections can be rather perplexing if
you're not as keen a puzzle solver
they take some outside of the box
thinking that shouldn't take you too
long to solve but if you're struggling
there is an option
to skip these sections entirely pause
the game and you'll see an option for it
letting you forego the section entirely
to just continue on the story
despite appearing fairly linear rift
apart's levels are quite sprawling
often there are forks in the road you
can take that'll lead you to resources
and collectibles
such as raritanium which you'll never
want to miss other times there are even
side objectives in a level that'll
reward you with some of the game's most
valuable collectibles
such as spybots which when you collect
them all unlock one of the most powerful
weapons in the game
don't hesitate to go off the beaten path
and explore you'll never know what
you'll find
and speaking of collectibles if you're a
collectible hunting monster like us then
rift apart is bound to satisfy the part
of you that yearns to spend
hundreds of hours rampaging through a
level looking for all its shiny
collectibles
we get it it fulfills that void in your
heart that just wants to feel
something but to make that job easier
for yourself we recommend
checking the map screen often as you
explore rift parts level maps have a
semi-fog of war quality to them meaning
you don't know where any collectibles
are
at least the ones you can't readily see
yourself until you get close to them
in which case the game will mark where
it is on the map as you navigate a
level's various twists and turns check
the map screen
often to see what it has marked because
chances are that you missed a valuable
box of raritanium or a gold bolt
tucked away in a corner that you
neglected to scour don't sweat it if you
can't get all of the levels collectibles
on the first go
some levels don't even allow you to get
everything at first when there's an area
that seems outside your capability to
reach then chances are you just need to
wait
until you get a new gadget or wait for a
new objective to open up that clears the
way forward
another collectible you'll get are armor
pieces that you can equip onto ratchet
and rivet
as you steadily gather pieces you'll
notice that each armor set offers a
special buff
such as increasing your melee damage or
reducing damage from pirates
however something you might not realize
is that you don't actually need to wear
any of the armor pieces to reap the
benefits of these buffs
they're all automatically applied to you
so you don't have to worry about
changing out arma suits during specific
instances
essentially armor is entirely cosmetic
but you should prioritize collecting
them all because those buffs will come
in handy the further along you get
one more thing you can edit the color of
any armor piece as soon as you equip it
by pressing square and selecting from
the various palette options
so if you want that galactic ranger
helmet to be a fine jet black with sick
yellow accents
you're welcome to it fortunately rift
apart does eventually offer
collectible hunters a break if you do
the treasure hunt optional quest on
ardolis you're rewarded with an item
that highlights the icon of nearly every
remaining collectable
in the game on your map unfortunately
though it won't mark craga bears a
secret collectible type that you get to
unlock a few of the game's trophies
after finishing up zerky's multiple call
asking you to come back to sargasso to
help out with a situation regarding
trudy an
alien pterodactyl looking creature if
you return you're treated to a new side
quest where you must collect
10 zerp stones to feed trudy the task
itself is simple but don't
try to be an overachiever return to mort
once you have enough zerp stones or else
you'll likely become confused as to why
you can't get to the stones in places
you can't even reach
talk to mort to receive your reward and
then he'll tell you to collect 30 zerp
stones for a ranger helmet
and then all zerp stones for a spybot
but this time you'll have trudy to help
who can fly you across sargasso quickly
and get you to those out of reach
serpstones
see this is why we told you not to
overachieve the job is easy
from here at least until you find
yourself confused again as to why you
can't collect the zip stones that aren't
near perches for trudy to mount on this
is because trudy needs to work her way
up to breathing fire which will only
happen once you collect around 45 zerp
stones
once you've found that many mount trudy
and mort will call you telling you she
can use her fire breath again
your key to getting that last lot of
pesky zerpstones
there you have it some crucial tips to
get you started in ratchet and clank
rift apart for more on ratchet and clang
and ps5 exclusives in general make sure
to subscribe to gamespot
see ya
you